Надзвичайно чутливі телескопи дають зможу астрономам
зазирнути в далеке минуле.
І ось так це виглядає: погляд у минуле.
Він показує всесвіт таким, яким він був майже
чотириста тисяч років після його народження.
Задовго до перших зірок
та формування галактик.
Як саме виник наш всесвіт і що сталося відразу після цього,
не можливо досліджувати
звичайним телескопом.
Одразу після великого вибуху сформувались гравітаційні хвилі,
які й досі коливаються у просторі.
Таким чином
гравітаційні хвилі можуть
відкрити вікно для дослідників.
Альберт Ейнштейн понад століття тому описав ці хвилі
у своїй загальній теорії відносності.
Вони виникають,
наприклад, коли зливаються чорні діри або вибухають
зірки.
Це можна порівняти з хвилями на поверхні води,
коли на неї щось падає.
У грудні 2015 року у космос запустили
супутник LISA Pathfinder -
випробувати у малих масштабах можливість виявляти ці ґравітаційні хвилі.
LISA робить це завдяки принципу
лазерного інтерферометра.
Зонд містить два однакових кубика
із золота й платини, ізольованих від будь-якого впливу.
Вони мають бути в абсолютній невагомості.
Їх позицію мають вираховувати за допомоги лазерів.
І зробити це - неймовірно точно!
Вдалося!
LISA Pathfinder досяг успіху. Усунули
найбільшу перешкоду для гравітаційно-хвильового детектора у космосі.
Тепер у 2034 році має розпочатись
масштабне дослідження,
участь у якому візьмуть три супутники.
Вони обмінюватимуться лазерними променями
у гігантському трикутнику, кожна зі
сторін якого сягатиме  двох з половиною мільйонів кілометрів.
таким чином
відстань від одного апарата до іншого вираховуватиметься з
точністю до мільярдної частки міліметра.
Завдяки такому надчутливому детектору дослідники зможуть
побачити гравітаційні хвилі, що їх генерують
чорні дірки у Всесвіті. Щоб нарешті з"ясувати -
як же вони впливають на розвиток галактики.